- Good afternoon.
- [Audience] Good afternoon.
- Lovely.
We are gonna talk about
the zero migration path
from data to enterprise agentic AI, okay?
It's a provocative title,
but hopefully, the conversation
will live up to the hype.
A quick word about Trianz.
We are an AWS ISV partner.
We work with AWS in multiple disciplines.
We bring a completely
different approach and a model
to help our customers transform,
and we call that as services as software.
We're gonna talk very quickly
about what our approach is
and what our capabilities are,
and then dive into this concept of
zero migration data to agentic ai.
We lead with a massive
platform called Concierto.
Concierto has five big
transformative solutions in it.
Number one is modernization.
Modernization of infrastructure
of data and applications
all at the same time, okay?
Number two is migrate.
Concierto can assess,
map out dependencies,
create waves, all of that stuff,
and move all the three
layers at the same time
to any of the three clouds
and between the clouds.
Number three, Concierto
allows you to manage
all of these environments
from a single pane of glass
with a single abstracted process.
Number four is maximize,
we use the word maximize
in sort of observability,
because what Concierto does
is it looks at consumption
patterns, capacity ,
events and all of that stuff,
and uses AI and ML to remediate
the use of these anomalies
so that you're able to optimize
how you're using the cloud.
And then the last piece
is insights in agentic AI,
which is what we are going to dive into.
Concierto us hosted on AWS.
We have over 60, 70 customers
in the last five months alone
who have adopted this,
not to mention a number
of customers worldwide
who are using the platform
through Concierto partners.
Before we talk about this
concept of data to agentic AI,
a quick word about our
experience and all things data,
and I'm double flicking here
specifically on federated data
and connecting with a
federated model, okay?
We have done a lot of work in this space,
but what is relevant here is
about four to five years ago,
we were the first company
to connect the AWS cloud
with data sources anywhere on the planet.
AWS subsequently acquired
the software from us,
and we ended up becoming a
very close strategic partner.
And we do a lot of engineering
services for AWS as well.
So this is the foundation on which
we are gonna be talking about this concept
of data to agentic AI without migrations.
Yesterday, AWS released
about a dozen connectors
to third party ISVs from the AWS Cloud.
Concierto and Trianz is the company that
built those connectors.
And we're gonna keep doing that
over the course of the next several years
until we are able to
create or co-create or help
in the design and the build
out of agentic cloud, okay?
So we are also working with AWS
in connecting the different layers
of the cloud itself, okay?
So that is the experience and perspective
that we bring to the table.
So let's dive into our subject today.
There are two really, really
big existential questions
that everybody in the board is asking.
And if you are anywhere
in the data landscape,
there is no hiding from
these two questions.
Question number one,
how much time do we have
to get ahead of AI?
It's not about getting too AI
because everybody else in your
industry is doing the same,
and therefore, you have to
put yourself in a position
where you're innovating
and coming up with ideas
that are ahead of the industry.
And you can only do that
when the foundation that you require
to reinvent the business using AI is late.
Number two is how much time
do we have to get there, okay?
So when we look at the way data
platforms are created today,
data platforms are modernized,
purchase, deployed,
whatever be the model, okay?
For a large company, a large enterprise,
it takes a minimum of 18
to 24 months to get there.
Now, until several years ago,
this approach was fine
because we all had time.
Now, what's happening around the world,
thanks to the innovators and
the leaders in any industry,
is that the change cycle,
the time in which
transformation of an entire
industry takes place,
or at least in the big spots, okay?
It's now less than 11 months.
No matter what industry you are in,
something big is changing
within 11, 12 months at most.
And so therefore, business in reality
is living on borrowed time.
So why take an approach that is expensive,
doesn't guarantee an outcome,
and is most likely going to be obsolete
by the time it is done, right?
The other thing that
we have to keep in mind
is fundamentally your data
is screaming and saying,
I don't want to move,
a large chunk of your data, okay?
And why is that?
Because there are compliance issues
due to which you have to
keep some data on prem,
you have stuff sitting on SaaS,
you make an acquisition,
you sell a business.
There are 15 different things above data,
technically speaking, that
are always changing, okay?
We may have a majority
of our data on one cloud,
which is fine, okay?
But the goal is not to
move the data itself,
the goal is to make use of
the data wherever it is.
And what is going to happen.
I'm sure we all read the same news.
Everybody is immersed these
days in understanding AI
and its effects and so on and so forth.
But what I'd like to suggest is
that ultimately the outcome
is going to be binary.
There are those that will succeed,
and there are those that will fail.
The old way of looking at
the middle of the ground,
the middle of the pack,
I don't think that that
middle of the pack paradigm
is gonna survive for a long time, okay?
Those who get it right,
obviously those who don't get it right
will see a very, very troublesome,
painful pattern in front of them, okay?
Slow obsolescence, customers walking away,
revenues going up and down, and so on.
And you'll come to a point where
you cannot reverse the trend.
We have seen enough examples in,
let's say the entertainment industry.
We have seen that in real estate,
we've seen that in retail,
we've seen that in fashion,
and it is going to happen
pretty much in every single
industry as we move forward.
But on the other hand,
those who get it right,
they're going to start
seeing revenue spiked.
Because there's customers
who are going to leave the
companies that are obsolete,
still need the services,
they still need the product.
So they're going to
move to those companies
that appeal to them and that
give them a better value
and what they're looking for.
So what we did specifically in this space
is we tore up our playbook
and we said we're gonna look at everything
from a clean sheet.
And what we set out to do is
to change the paradigm and build
a very, very different approach
to get from data to insights
as fast as possible, okay?
As quickly as possible.
Number two is make it
really, really simple
for the business to be able to use.
And number three is make it
scalable across the company.
In order for us to do this,
we examine six fundamental questions
that keep data leaders
awake all the time, okay?
How do we enable AI
on our existing assets
without moving them?
How do we productize data
and look at data in small pieces
as opposed to running expensive,
time consuming queries
and so on and so forth.
How do we break the
bottleneck of business to IT?
I need something today.
And the data guy says,
"I have a six weeks SLA
to deliver that, right?"
Business doesn't have time anymore.
How do we break that, okay?
How do we achieve governance
in large enterprises
without the bureaucracy
that goes along with it
and the time that we lose?
And number five is how do we get people
in the data universe,
your architects, your data scientists,
your governance folks,
your security folks,
they all need to be able to
look at the same picture.
And then finally, how can we
do this as fast as possible?
So we artificially put a
stake in the ground and said,
we should be able to do this in 90 days.
And here is how we solve problems.
Number one is we connected with data
structured and unstructured in real time
using a federated concept, okay?
We can connect with data pretty
much anywhere on the planet,
and if we can't,
we'll be able to build
it in four to six weeks.
Number two is we productize data
based on how it is used,
not based on how it is stored, okay?
Really, really fast using AI,
by your business domains,
by your data domains.
Number three, the entire
platform is built on zero code.
So nobody has to type any queries
and do a lot of technical stuff
in order to get to the results.
Number four is we use governance
that companies have built
over decades at source,
and we enhance those governance rules
as opposed to lifting and
shifting all of the data
and then rewriting and
rebuilding the stuff, okay?
Number five is that we assess
everything in one shot.
And about four to five weeks,
we are able to get
everybody from data teams,
including your business on the
same page as to where we are
and where we are going
and what does it really take for us
at the applications
level, at the data level
and infrastructure level to
be ready for agentic AI, okay?
And yes, we are being able
to break the 90 day barrier.
So I'll now leave you with
some concepts, some visuals,
so that you can understand
what this Concierto Insights
and agentic AI platform is about, okay?
Number one is federated data connectivity.
No matter where your data is,
on-prem, on cloud, on SaaS,
wherever it is, we are able
to connect to it instantly.
Number two is we are able to
productize data and catalog it.
Number three, we publish
the data in a marketplace
that is very similar to
Amazon Prime Video or Netflix.
Take your pick, okay?
So it's very intuitive for business users
to be able to see data,
just like you see movie
titles by genre, okay?
Sales, sales finance, sales compensation,
sales ops, and so on and so forth, okay?
So we organize data
very, very intuitively.
And number four is we have Native Gen BI,
native conversational AI,
but you can also integrate
with tools that you may have
invested in already, okay?
Conversational AI and then
ultimately agentic marketplaces.
Let's take a very quick
look at this, okay?
So Concierto brings universal
connectivity, as I said.
Number two is we use AI
to rapidly productize,
within hours and days.
Your entire data the
way you want to see it
and the way you're going
to consume it, okay?
Real time, zero copy.
Concierto doesn't store any of your data,
it sits at your source.
It only brings the results from queries
to generate the insights that you need.
On the other hand, if you
want to start migrating data
and do just the incremental stuff,
we can create a copy on
the cloud as well, okay?
Intelligent caching, that's
what we are talking about
and it accelerates future
queries and so on and so forth.
Governance, as I said, it's at source.
Number two, enterprise data marketplace.
Each of these cool tiles that
you see has a bunch of icons.
What those icons are showing
business and IT teams
just like a movie title user
ratings or a TV show rating
is discovery, lineage, okay?
You can join two data products
and create a super data product
and still see the entire lineage, okay?
Data quality, usage,
and how ready this particular data set is
for agentic tech stuff, okay?
Now, this exposes data to users
as they want to consume it,
but it also tells data teams
as to what their target should be.
For example, if I have
a data quality problem
across the enterprise,
I don't have to solve it across the board,
I can solve it for my
high priority data sets
to make sure that the results of those
are much more accurate, okay?
Those stuff like that.
Now, every company today has
invested large enterprises,
especially in some sort
of BI capabilities.
We're not here to ask
companies to replace those
and buy yet another tool.
Concierto is automatically connected
to Tableau and Power BI and
AWS QuickSight and so on.
But in order to truly help democratize,
Concierto also has Native
Gen BI capabilities, okay?
It brings your cost down
and it helps everybody in
the company truly used data.
So this is data democratization
in real life, okay?
Concierto is built on the AWS stack, okay?
So Anthropic, Claude,
Bedrock, SageMaker, et cetera.
On top of that, we've
written thousands of rules,
which make your queries
much more intelligent,
much more precise, and very, very fast.
And so your business users
can essentially come in
and start having a
conversation with their data.
You don't need to create canned reports
and keep feeding them every
week, every three days,
whatever the periodicity is, okay?
So what the conversational AI
piece does for any data set
that a user has access to,
it automatically read through
what data needs to be read
to answer the query
and give you quantitative
insights, charts,
and even decisions that the
user needs to make, okay?
And then the last piece in this obviously
is enterprise agentic marketplaces, okay?
Now, when we've gotten our
applications and our data ready
after seeing the scores
and making improvements
and so on and so forth,
Concierto has a capability where
the data teams and the application teams
can start designing agents
and make those agents available to users
to embed in their processes
and automate decision making
and execution and so
on and so forth, okay?
Now, this whole journey starts
with a very simple exercise
called DALAI, right?
Called name, as in Dalai Lama, right?
It's about wisdom, it's
about getting informed,
getting educated, right?
So when you deploy
Concierto in your landscape,
the platform will
generate a report for you,
covering your data, it's demographics,
where it is stored physically, virtually,
how is it growing, what is the
profile of your database is,
what exists out there, what goes out,
what is end of life
and so on and so forth?
What is your provisioning?
What is your storage?
Quality, security, all of this stuff
is laid out very neatly.
And on top of that,
you and our teams will work
together to create a scorecard
for agent AI readiness.
You give the rules, you add the rules
to the rules that are
already in the platform.
And for each of the data sets,
by business function, by data domain,
the platform is gonna tell you
whether or not that data
is ready for agentic AI,
if not, what needs to be done, okay?
Once all of this is done,
we lay neatly in the form of a report
that your business users and
your IT leaders can consume.
And then we are off and running.
But the beauty of this approach
is while we are doing the assessment,
teams can work together and configure
Concierto insights and
agentic AI for real world use.
So what we begin with is a 90 day exercise
in which we take one business
unit or one business function,
create a template for you
for using the platform
the way I described.
And in parallel, we train teams
so that this becomes a
self-service capability
inside the organization
as opposed to data teams needing an SI
or some consulting firm
to come and do all of
this work for you, okay?
So while the leaders are
consuming the feedback
from the agentic AI and the
data assessment that we do,
the platform gets ready
and in 90 days, you'll
be able to turn it on
and make it available to your users.
The good news in all of these assessments
is that they are funded by AWS, okay?
So you do not have to spend a lot of money
just to get an assessment done.
We and AWS are partnering
to fund this for customers
and deliver these reports for free, okay?
After that, you can choose
to continue if you like it.
There's no obligation.
You don't have to continue the platform
if for whatever reason, you don't, right?
So that's the offer
that we are bringing to the table
for every customer and even partners
who want to use this platform
for their end customers as well, right?
I was not supposed to say that,
but in the background,
if you are truly married to
moving your data to the cloud,
now that we have decoupled it,
Concierto can also migrate
your databases, modernize them,
and move the data itself
to the cloud, okay?
And it can create lake houses on the fly
on cloud native technology
as opposed to very, very
expensive third party tools.
So that really is the path
from getting from data
to agentic AI in 90 days.
Good?
Perfect.
(audience clapping)
Thank you.
Exactly 13 seconds.
So no time for questions, unfortunately.
But Trianz is at booth 1381.
There are a number of folks
here from Trianz as well.
Please stop by and let's
have a conversation.
Thank you very much.